simple interest and compound interest
they both make money grow in fact on a
write that down simple and compound
interest they're both about getting a
fancy term is a return on investment
they both make money grow return on
investment sometimes you'll see that if
you ever read the newspaper and you're
you open up the finance section or maybe
you'd like your parents have left it
open and they sometimes I'll use the at
the other the acronym ROI that means you
invest money that's what this topic is
called investing money right and you
expect to get some return on it you
expect people to pay you back for you
having let them use your money okay
so simple compound interest they both do
that they both do that but they do it in
different ways very different ways and
what this table is about is helping you
see the difference and appreciate it and
get how different they are okay so let's
consider an example we're going to do a
lot of working sort of along the side or
maybe if you didn't have space
underneath your table and then we're
going to transfer what we've worked into
this table so we can see it all in one
nice picture okay so let's think about a
nice easy sum of money a thousand
dollars is invested now I think the
interest rate that we've been running
with for a while it's been six percent
six percent per annum okay so for the
sake of simplicity let's stay with that
okay the interest rate
is 6% madam
okay now what we want to do is track
this money and this interest rate with
these two kinds of interest and see it
over time I think that would illustrate
what's going on really well okay so
first let's consider simple interest all
right now let's just consider one year
one year we know what the simple
interest formula is it's I equals PRN
well done okay so we know what our
principal is the amount that they stuck
in the bank $1,000 the rate here we want
it as a decimal right so six percent as
a decimal is well done 0.06 okay
I just wanted after one year so n is
equal to one so that's going to be how
much mmm six percent of a thousand
dollars I think it's going we're gonna
end up with a thousand and sixty but
just the interest is just sixty it's
just okay now let's put that over here I
want to know how much I've got after one
year right I got this much interest and
I started with this much right so the
total be a thousand and sixty I've got
one year okay
let's consider what happens when we wait
another 12 months okay so this was after
one year
let's go again two years okay so the
interest again will be P and everything
will be the same but what will change
just-just-just the end right on the end
so it'll still be a thousand it'd still
be 0.06 but now it's gonna be - okay so
one of the numbers gonna be it's gonna
be just like this but twice as big yeah
which is a hundred and twenty good all
right so now considering what's happened
after this law how much do I have in
there
I've got this hundred twenty plus three
thousand dollars and I started now
what's going on every time I'm adding
that's $60 this $6 it just gets added
over and over again so in fact I don't
need to go through this whole thing
I don't need to use the formula I think
we can fill out the rest of these rows
just by thinking about what happens from
year to year okay if I add $60 on every
single year what's gonna happen after
three all I'd be up to the 20 plus 60
gives you that 80 okay if I go another
year that 60 is gonna it's good 60 plus
80 it's going to carry the one so I
think we could get 12 40 here right and
if you're in doubt you can use your
calculator to check any of these numbers
I'm pretty sure we should get up to
1,300 by you 5 which means the last year
is 1360 good
cool we can see what's happened after
certain number of years that's good
right
now I want to do the comparison I want
to see what happens in same money same
interest rate but this time they let us
compound okay Bob I've accounted for
these calculations I've already put him
into the table so I'm just gonna delete
this right and now I want to think about
compound interest okay okay I don't know
how many of you read your own bank
statements or how about have a look
online and see what's happening and
what's your money grow this is what it's
going to do we know that the competitor
swarm is different right first say it
starts with an A what's over here
it's quite different right do you
remember have you got there your books
we want the compound interest formula P
okay it's a 1 by the way
don't baby be careful it's a 1/1 which
makes a big difference actually so I now
when I rehearse the same person I want
to think about what happens from year to
year
okay now let's think about the first
year the first year okay
the principles are thousand dollars
right all the numbers are the same right
the rate is still 0.06 and the number of
years is still 1 the numbers are the
same but we're doing different things
with them okay watch what happens and
this is a thousand times 1.06 right
what's that gonna be equal to you have
to be with the decimal place right
there's three zeros here so I'm gonna
move the decimal place three times
yeah it's going to be hold on a second
let me just get that 1 2 3
that's where the decimal place should be
you know so that's a thousand and sixty
wait a second that's a bit disappointing
isn't it
after what year you have exactly the
same amount whether you got compound or
simple okay but what happens that you're
after
okay let's consider what happens after
two years you know principal still the
same the interest rate is still the same
but now I go for another year okay this
is 1,000 times 1.06 squared and you want
your calculator for this one okay what I
end up doing I can't do it because I've
given up my calculators away despite
coming in so many or we get one thousand
one hundred twenty three point six and
because it's money it's sixty cents
isn't it okay so you look and you see
what happens okay I can focus here how
much am i ahead whoa
I've reached three dollars and sixty
cents what can you do with three dollars
and sixty cents go out and get like that
get it you get it you get a chicken
burger and enough applies the moon for
that not bad okay and still have ten
cents change not a bad deal but still
not super impressive
okay well let's continue what happens
you can see the difference between this
and this right it's just this number so
on your calculator if you typed in one
thousand times one point five six
squared okay all you need to do is and
I'm going to borrow it back so it's
calculator per second what are you gonna
do it is go data on this your replay
button right here it curses
press up up should take you back to your
previous calculation go to the two and
you can just change the two you don't
have to go through and change the whole
re-type the whole thing just go
backwards change that to into a three
so three years it'll be 1,000 you change
that to up there into a three and what
do you get
what what dollar ninety one point zero
zero one six so I guess that would ran
up to two wouldn't it one six oh two
cents they go okay now this is three
dollars sixty ahead right but I'm
starting to stretch out now I know I'm
now eleven dollars and two cents
the gap is why didn't you write I
started out at exactly the same thing
one year then I was you know a beggar in
a bit ahead and now like you'd get a
decent meal for that right okay let's go
again I want to see what happens after
four years and five years and six years
I wonder what the gap will be okay
you're going to get the same kind of
thing but you're just changing the index
the power
okay can we get some numbers someone
else are you something up the back can
they tell us I gave our calculators
who's using those that's okay
maybe someone who hasn't got they
calculator using you right now maybe you
should do a different view some could do
for some can do five companies whose the
whole you or for you don't you're
finished okay um can you give us Paul we
get someone else to use fun no let's
leave it what's after the seven okay can
anyone verify how many cents you get
after that six if I put four seven I'm
trying to work out what this exact
number is I just wanna know which way it
round don't round you know as if you're
paying by cash don't round to the
nearest five or ten cents just go to the
nearest cent in bank accounts it stays
to the exact set in fact it even stays
to information after that they just
don't show you because we're are they
interested in have you sent anyone
verify what do you get 24/7
well someone give me back again so I can
verify
here four seven six nine six four seven
so it actually rounds up that four seven
becomes a four doesn't it so do be
careful with that that you can go back
and change that next you a five
thank you now the last thing that's left
for me it's just just compare right like
I like I said I was trying to do and see
how far ahead I was wasn't ahead at all
3.60 ahead $11 in a bit of head what's
this that's like that's 22 dollars a
head isn't it $22.48 a head here $38 and
23 cents a head here
mmm 58 I think so you can see here on
year the gaps getting bigger and it's
getting bigger faster in fact we have a
special name for this not that you need
to know it but this is called
exponential growth right things get
bigger and the bigger they are the
faster they grow all right
exponential growth that's what this
power does okay that's what we call it
and explain it or an index okay
it's um making money grow both of them
are but this is fundamentally faster
okay this is kind of plotting a wall at
an even pace okay
and this guy's running and getting
faster and faster as he goes which is
why this gap is widening okay